we've been looking at solving equations
that have complex solutions
and we've noticed that there are
basically two ways to do that either
your coefficients of your equation can
be complex which
unsurprisingly leads to complex
solutions or alternatively as you see in
this case
even with just real coefficients in your
equation if you have a quadratic or a
cubic or anything of a higher order
even with just real coefficients you
sometimes end up with complex
solutions so that's what we're going to
have a look at in this question and
by going through the results that are
being asked for us to prove here we're
actually going to
come up with one of the really nice
theorems within complex numbers let's
get tucked into this consider the
quadratic equation
a z squared plus b z plus c equals zero
where a
b c are real so like we were saying
before
this is one of those cases where all of
our coefficients are going to be real
that'll become important later
and b squared minus 4ac which you might
recognize
as the discriminant that discriminant is
negative now of course
when you're solving a quadratic equation
in the quadratic formula
the discriminant is the thing that sits
underneath the square root
so it used to be before we knew about
complex numbers that if you said
that the discriminant was less than zero
we would normally say oh you're not
going to find any roots
more technically correctly would say
there are no real roots because the
discriminant is less than zero but we're
allowing for complex solutions
that's why the immediate next sentence
says there are going to be complex roots
to this equation
and we're going to call this by the way
that's not a w it's a
greek letter you might not have
encountered yet it's a lower case
omega so we're going to suppose that
omega is one of the complex roots of the
equation
so then what are they asking us to prove
it says for part a
explain why a omega squared plus b omega
plus c equals 0. all right so
this is not meant to be an arduous
question but you need to think logically
about
what is the relationship between the
roots of an equation and the equation
itself so before we tuck into this
particular one which really isn't going
to be
very dramatic let's just think about an
example where we know things a little
bit better
if you had for instance let's just say
consider
a quadratic equation that we're pretty
familiar with like say x squared plus 5x
plus 6 equals 0. now you've probably
solved this particular equation zillions
of times before because
it has nice numbers and it's easy to
deal with we could say
x equals 2 or sorry x equals negative 2
or x equals negative 3
we could say they are the roots of this
equation now what does that actually
mean well if we were to say x
equals negative 2 is a root what that
means is
we could take that value negative 2 and
we could actually substitute it into the
equation and it should satisfy
the equation and that's very easy to
demonstrate in an example like this
if i take that negative 2 and then
square it i'm going to add 5 lots of
negative 2
i'm going to add 6. let's just go ahead
and crunch the numbers on this right
negative 2 times negative 2 is 4 5 lots
of negative 2 is
minus 10 plus 6 and hopefully it doesn't
take too much to convince yourself
that that's equal to 0. and we could
obviously go through exactly the same
exercise for x equals negative 3
because that's also a root now what that
means is
if you have a particular value and it's
a root of your particular equation
that's another way of saying that
particular value satisfies the equation
you started with
now in this case for the question we're
interested in they're calling one of the
roots omega they're just giving it that
name
right they're saying omega is one of the
complex roots of this equation
so i can say here's my actual here's my
part a
proof if you can call it that right
since
z equals omega is
a root it satisfies the equation
and so because the equation is uh a
i'll should write that down a z
squared plus b z plus c
just squeeze it in equals 0. what that
means is
to satisfy the equation means if we
substitute it in it all
works it's still equal so i can say a
omega squared
plus b omega plus c equals
zero i told you it wasn't much of a
proof that's the whole thing
okay so that's my explanation it's a
root therefore it satisfies the equation
but how do they want us to use this
let's have a look at part b
together it says by taking the conjugate
of
both sides of the result in a so this is
the result in a
they're asking us to take the conjugate
to both sides and
using the properties of conjugates
whatever that means
show that and then there's this result
here okay so let's have a think about
this
this is where we want to end up
and where we're going to begin is in the
first half of the question it says by
taking the conjugate
of both sides of this result so let's
see what happens when we do that
here is the result from part a
and taking the conjugates of both sides
my notation is this bar that goes over
the top
right so taking the conjugate of both
sides is an operation just like
differentiating both sides or squaring
both sides
we presume that if the two things
started off equal then once you apply
this operation to both sides identically
then the result is equal so so far so
good
not much too dramatic here but how do i
get from this
to this what am i going to do here well
this is where
this suggestion is going to come in
using the properties of conjugates so
there are several properties that i'm
going to have to use and we've looked at
these before when we first
introduced the idea of conjugates which
is very early on before you even knew
about the polar form of a complex number
or the exponential form
the conjugate of a complex number we
define right from the beginning
based on rectangular form or cartesian
form right if i had
you know some some complex number z
right if that was equal to
x plus i y something in cartesian form
then we define z bar the complex
conjugate
to be x minus i y
i'll say if that then this okay so what
we want to do
is use this sort of definition and then
some of the properties that come
from this definition to get from here
to our desired result okay so how we're
going to do that
there's a few different directions and a
few steps we need to go through here
i'm going to go through them in an order
that i hope makes sense to you
the first thing i notice is that i have
one big conjugate
over here on the left hand side and
eventually i'm going to have like
several separate terms that some of
which involve conjugates and some of
which don't
so what i need to do is take this big
single conjugate
and break it into several pieces okay
and what i have here
is the conjugate of a sum of separate
things right and don't forget
omega is a complex root so omega is a
complex number itself
so what i'm doing is when i have these
complex numbers in here
i'm taking the conjugate of the sum of
those things
what is the conjugate of a sum equal to
we can prove this result fairly fairly
simply
if we can come up with two arbitrary
complex numbers and add them together
see what happens when we have a look at
the conjugates so i've already defined
some arbitrary some general complex
number z
in this way let's uh let's introduce a
friend like say w
and i need different coefficients here
so let's call it a
plus i b i know i've got an a and a b
over here as well but let's let's sort
of keep this separate to prove our
results which we're going to use
in this particular deductive proof now
if
w is a plus ib then
its conjugate w bar is equal to a
minus ib okay now what i'm contemplating
here is
the conjugate of a sum
of complex numbers right so what happens
if i add these two complex numbers a z
and w and then take the conjugate well
let's let's have a go
z oopsie daisy z plus w
is just going to be well let's have a
look i've just chosen x plus i y
uh plus a plus i b
there's z there's w so that's plainly z
plus w in order to work out what the
conjugate of this whole thing
this whole um this whole sum right in
order to work out what that conjugate is
i should separate out the real part and
the imaginary part so that i can just
take the imaginary part and
turn it to the opposite side if it was
minus i'd make it plus if it's plus i
make it
minus so what i'm going to do is i'll
separate out the real bits
that looks like x plus a though
those parts have no imaginary unit
attached to them and then what i'll do
is i'll factorize out an
i from everything else because that
leaves me with this i y and this ib
and that makes it very clear if i
factorize out i
that this entire section here this is
the imaginary part
okay so there's z plus w i haven't taken
the conjugate yet
now if i take the conjugate of the left
hand side then by
definition the real part remains
unchanged
like so and the imaginary part i flip
the sign around well
currently it's a plus i'm going to
change it into a minus
okay so i get i y plus
b and like so so how does this relate to
the other conjugates that i have up here
well hopefully you can see
the x and the a are the same but then
i've got
the minus i b and the minus i y that
come from z bar and w bar right
i can see that just by expanding so what
i can do is i can say
the x plus a they're just hanging out
the front i'll expand here
i y minus i b and now if i just kind of
collect around the different
letters or sort of correct collect is
the wrong word i'm just going to
rearrange to
put the relevant letters next to each
other x went with
y and a went with
b so you can see what i've got here if i
just put some helpful parentheses here
this is z bar by definition
there it is right up there and here is
w bar because you can see that's where i
wrote it down
so in summary when i have the
conjugate of a sum that is equivalent to
the sum of the conjugates that's nice
and easy to remember okay
so essentially what i have proved here
this property allows me
to take this big conjugate on the left
hand side
and break it into pieces everything
that's added up underneath i can write
it as a
as its own separate conjugate okay so
let's have a go at that in fact i'm
going to do it in a super lazy way
i'm going to take everything and what
i'm going to do is i'm going to say look
i can actually
separate that conjugate and that country
there you go so
on the left hand side i had um the
conjugate of three separate terms added
together
and i can say based on this this
property here
that this is the sum of these three
separate conjugates okay
so far so good